[Music]
today was chick-fil-a appreciation day
he's welcome Chaz the intolerant
chick-fil-a chicken happy chick-fil-a
Appreciation Day ladies and gentlemen
but not gentlemen and gentlemen that's
wrong in the eyes of God hey I'm sorry
chance I think you're being a little
narrow-minded there it's in Leviticus
chapter 18 the only mouth-watering hunk
of meat a man should put in his mouth is
our chick-fil-a clapping
pretty sure that's not in Leviticus
chad's well it should be and remember
fellas if you want a bunch of fruits
crowding around your nuts and a belly
full of protein try our granola yogurt
parfait
[Applause]
Chaz that's disgusting
well so are civil unions and lady if you
want a munch on a sweet Mound that was
designed by God for pleasure try our
soft-serve cones
it's a fistful of fun okay you know
chess you got stop you got stop now and
fell it if you want to be serviced for
cash rot in your car by a guy you've
never met before try our drives are you
encouraging yeah right when remember
folks it's Adam and Eve not Adam and
Steve and a chick-fil-a it's cockadoodle
do not doodle do a cop
[Applause]
- yeah it's not true why am I looking
here when you're right there
Chaz the intolerant chick-fil-a chicken
I'm sorry eat up you gobblers saw
tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]